[Music]
today on true news youtubers fallout
makeup make love not yeah that wouldn't
work we technically work but it's
something like there everyone work right
Turner mojo and Jake Paul together those
lips Phil what do you get it's filled
with did they take it out your odds this
video is not made at all - like crucify
Brad he's a person who made some
mistakes and I have made so many
mistakes in my life what a rational look
I don't know why she's going with this
book well I don't want anyone to get
crucified I saw it with Jesus and it was
horrible that was 2000 years ago we're
still reeling off of it I would love to
see a youtuber sort of live crucified
but not Brad I'm sure the majority of
you know that I don't believe in
canceled culture and they're over and
like whatever like people make really
bad mistakes I wonder if she's like
double bluffing us here whatever you do
do not cancel him yeah I wouldn't want
anyone to put a bomb under Brad's car I
wouldn't want anyone to try and do a hit
or taking Brad you want to take a
baseball bat to his face I think the
most important thing for me is that
Brad's wallet doesn't take a hit from
this so because Brad needs to be able to
keep up with all the women that he was
[__] behind my back I don't want them
to suffer because of this okay I want
them to get the best it's oh god what
something to know just to be clear
you've cried on camera what did it feel
like when you were crying on camera it's
different than a breakup but did it feel
a little bit weird I never intended to
put my know I was sort of just you sent
it to me and what's this like and even I
was going oh you just want to hold him
down
I think a lot of people know they're
gonna cry before they make a video and
it's sort of all part of a plan
mmm that wasn't what I was going for
yeah and I'm saying hence why happen one
time and probably only will ever happen
that one day unless I win the lottery
[__] see it's been nice making
videos good night Vienna and then you
just get up and walk out
even split the money with me because I
would say yeah good afternoon good
evening tonight and tell Lawrence it was
lovely working with ya but I don't need
that [__] anymore but she doesn't want
you to cancel them she did loads of
things from he tried a like share and
she's making this public video to let
you know but whatever happens don't take
that out on him you know when someone
lives their life on camera should they
put this kind of thing on camera because
this is being honest I'm right and she
live every moment on camera like a few
wipes are off after taking a massive
[__] is that on camera I don't actually
have maybe it should be I don't know
does this need to be oh maybe there
might be people watching this who are
going through a breakup themselves and
they're like ah I'm not alone I do feel
empty inside
maybe he's sitting there on the other
side with Gordon if you hadn't been such
a [__] maybe I would have been loyal my
whole life is just doing a lot of [__]
for a lot of people and a lot of people
want speaking from experience yeah
in order to get a lot of subscribers on
YouTube you need to be selfish I mean it
is literally a most unselfish for that
reason you have to dedicate yourself to
you in building your own [__] you know
who are selfless people serving the
homeless at shelters they're doing a lot
of [__] for a lot of people you my
friend you're raking in the money off of
drama do you know who's really selfless
that people who sit alongside the people
who collect the CPM and never [__]
share it I've met a lot of egotist in my
life
true Geordie a meme ulis [__] me will
any oh my god Stephen try and since come
Kirkham got all those subscribers
he ain't keeping this shut anymore sound
off most the most down-to-earth thought
of all of you who would've thought I
wouldn't cuz I've met him and I thought
he made a response video right he hasn't
been written in the sepia and the stare
that camera what does he true Geordie to
those before in you dis yourself a
little bit yeah 2014 no no no 2016
people have it twisted saying that I
cheated on her during the weekends
that's not true that did not happen
I never physically touched another girl
during our relationship ever
and I did snapchat a few girls from back
home and they did send me nudes and I
replied I was you know
drunks stupid didn't realize what was
going on a fair play he's holding his
hands if they send him nerds what's it
what's he supposed to do
he probably replied and said please
don't send me anything I guarantee
that's not what he said how old is this
guy but he's like in his early 2020 when
girls send me nudes when you're that age
like what you're supposed to do what do
you do you do not click that and you
know you definitely you have to be like
what someone sent me I better just check
just to be sure it's a virus and you
watch the whole video to make sure
there's no viral there's no point that
there are virus because I think this is
a 59 second thing you know I mean we
need to check this whole every second go
well you ever check it twice yeah double
check regardless I'm an idiot every
single day I just wish I could just take
back what I did because I really regret
answering just these stupid pointless
people now unhappy relationships people
will probably send nudes or do those
sorts of things
you know you've probably regrets he got
nudes from someone who wasn't as good as
Tanner and he downgraded there's
something an old man once told me an
upstanding penis knows no mercy bro
who told you that it was like a
grandfather figure was he wearing but
until I worried what he didn't know what
he was doing because he was very horny
oh man he was drunk he was horny real
we've all been there in a weird turn of
events Tanner is now with Jake [__]
Paul or Jay Paul said to her I know how
we can make something out of this let's
pretend we're hooking up I must admit
that you wouldn't be surprised
oh they're good there you go got to say
about people a lot I wasn't reading as
many other come I never dive into the
comment I love to know what the people
have to say I'm not gonna lie this is
just two people just enjoying that
everyone cares if they do something you
know when you do so lemon we're sort of
that bottom bit now it's hard to get the
juice out it is you know they're
literally going people are looking at us
yes a lot of people look at YouTube what
do we do now
what do we do now let's do a mock how is
it that Brad cheated and yet I feel
sorry for Brad in this situation
I kind of feel like Brad's the lucky one
he gets to walk down by Brad can just go
back to his normal welcome you're very
different stuff on your Instagram I have
gem wolfy she is a [__] star she read
it not she's not good at basketball Nina
she bounces one youtube song was
recently republished on YouTube after
being made on a battery now they want to
bait names how can a man who's friends
of a family or dad you republish that
video even after sort of GG I sent the
check them down or they sort of squashed
it and now JJ is like [__] mate yeah
what are you putting that out there for
that genuinely upset me I mean you're my
brother you're not supposed to be
dissing me and siding with the enemy I
did you just a note on your banner
you've lit your picture but it says tank
backwards now not good for Brandon yeah
it says that okay silent so JJ tweeted
out and he was really really pissed and
he's like I hope you never get 10
million subscribers and to be fair
daddy's being stuck on 9.7 for the long
time for a while so JJ said the keemstar
that there was literally nothing that
spot this are awesome yeah well we'll
watch this space so as it happens JJ's
got a new music video I'll bring within
a watch that our guy Khan directed it
can't come and stand it yeah New Age I
like that song I'd be listen that one
specifically the more I listen to it the
more I like you
this will be my second list
do you think this is better than Red
Alert
my PR told me not songs I think it's
better already okay drink from the
bottle while making that puddle pull up
the server to clean up the bubbles you
want to sit for the glorious like I'm
the Warriors you wanna test at the
double how much should the caucus run
there was only one 11 models GP in PE
that was fantastic by the way
JJ's got a magical duster he's a
gangster
and then Jimmy's the detective he's a
reporter he's the report okay Jamie's
going around taking pictures reporting
on the news of what JJ is notorious and
glorious you might say that guy who's
hanging upside down earned his wages
acted it Lamas having the right [__]
ball double from the union yeah yeah
blood rush to the head royalty when I
speaking to me I'm a G when it comes to
the guap I get em soon that play when I
stop I can't believe that you had a pork
again and you needed gangsters it was so
tough finding them honestly I went far
and wide so you just didn't have a clue
I needed like underground mobster he
blew actually hard yeah not just soft
boys who sometimes punch and make
reaction videos right imagine how good
the video would have been though if
you'd have Brian and imagine how many
more people would have watched it they
would have loved that Pete the people
would have loved that I'm sorry guys
next time
sticking around in YouTube for our last
story in the true news on on the
youtubes James Charles obviously has
been under a lot of criticism people
wonder what the [__] are we gonna get
from a 500-pound ticket we might have a
little bit of insight for you
he's got a bad singer is he happy do I
want to go too much James shall sing if
no face-painting nothing you mean make
up Bryan come on all respect for all of
that I'm sorry James
you're not going to bootcamp oh you'd
love it yeah with all those soldiers
singing 'he's not for everyone
sticking with some music whose milkshake
brings all the boys to the yard damn
right it's better than yours damn right
I can't stay in my country I don't see
Achilles lyric in reference to Tommy
Robinson as much as everyone's got an
idea of who Tommy Robinson is like you
should just judge this for what it is do
you know I'm saying you two people
having an argument in the street really
yeah surrounded by ETL folks you know I
love Tommy gets coupling why do you that
make why are you doing now
Tommy do it do it Tommy
whether we agree with Tommy's views or
not we wouldn't endorse you going
throwing milkshakes all the people but
some of the memes that came out with
this they were funny there's a food that
describe that that's a lot of dicks
Tommy Robinson covered in with speaking
of politics Game of Thrones me and Dan
Portman watch the episode together
aka Podrick was very late a lot of
whiskey involved let me let me bring
people up to speed I'm not happy
the latest episode of Game of Thrones I
thought about Game of Thrones is a story
that steep in complex storylines that
are setting up things to happen later on
and right now we're in the last three
episodes where he'd been flying in this
playing along for quite a lot of time
he's a pine and we're bring we're about
to bring this playing in the land and
it's imperative that these writers get
it right people have been waiting like a
decade to find out what the [__] up and
see a long time and it feels like
they're ignoring all of these set up
what points that they have been making
for years in favor of this will surprise
them I've invested a long time into this
[__] short
stay a long time well you need to get
this right now this is like two three
movies this is 70 [__] episodes by
watching the [__] the night king yeah
we've been building him up for years
he's supposed to be the biggest baddest
guy
he's Robotnik II dies in his first
battle after break and over the world
what a [__] amateur not let it die as
well it's the biggest setup for the
least possible return without the need
for brands visions without the need for
sums revision at the big library and
without a sword battle that has been
teased with Jon Snow
for decades I'd be waiting for these
guys to lock swords not I feel like you
shouted at me there was this big
prophecy about a prince who was promised
and we've been learning the whole time
er how Johnson or secretly a prince he
was going to be the one to defeat the
night king and yeah technically he got
everyone there and you know he kind of
set up this big bar he was the producer
oh yeah gets all the glory now Arya is
probably my favorite game of Thrones
character so I'm kind of happy that but
the visions and Sam's revision and and
Jon sauna and the prophecy now ii mean
nothing because all of a sudden were
like naddis Latoya okay other things
that didn't make sense like why have you
sent the Dothraki just to a certain
death yeah and why if you've got a big
barricade around the castle that you can
set on fire to protect you why have all
your people stand in front and that
barrack get annoyed put them behind it
yeah save wise yeah what the game of
thrones show me as love is a lust ii
Savior right when you think they're dead
someone saves the day yeah all I used it
to a point where a lot of the time it
doesn't make logical sense you see so
many [__] zombies going towards a
person you're like they'd be dead at
that point they're gone
yeah and and they still survive it so
can we get a bit more logic moving
forward and I know that this show is
about dragons and about [__] like
that but still we've got to retain some
credibility just don't [__] it up now
don't [__] it up now okay people are
counting on you to get this right sophie
turner who plays Sansa she had just
gotten married to George ominous new
photos from Joe Jonas and sophie Turner
surprised Las Vegas wedding oh my god I
guess I guess he's Julia Elvis must have
married
Vegas Elvis and the joke rose finally a
shot guy gets lucky I think he's a lot
older than her but I think it's cool
when like celebrities don't do the usual
huge wedding [__] and they're just
like we're gonna have some fun we're
just gonna do it our way
like when you watch Sophie's Instagram
so she comes across as a cool girl yeah
I think should be a good laughs Oh
Cassady volatile you say random words
have to be real thing Cassady Valentine
searches she is a youtuber and she got
lip fillers they went wrong yes I've
told girls don't be doing this to
yourself and I just wanted to reinforce
up they're not nice are their eyesight I
feel this no it must have been a thing
that can happen when you put this [__]
in your face yeah right now she's got no
lip fillers oh look at how lovely those
lips she's got a perfectly nice lips do
you not I mean I definitely normal no
but they're big anyway like if you want
nice big lips she's already got I once
had that with a wasp that is nuts can
also say that must be so traumatic to go
through it we just made [__]
terrifying
I just can't imagine doing that your
face I can't really benefit from some I
can't imagine what new like what we've
got is what we've got you know I mean I
guess I never noticed it until I came to
London like and when you go out in
London most these girls is that
something in the [__] water
sorry I didn't realise the koi carp look
was it missus which point did you
[__] o'clock
yeah something not right right I do
wonder how long because I'm sure that
you're sat there thinking maybe it will
go down as well no but you would be
thinking this is probably the swelling
down
the next day I'll be fine like she
probably thought that you might have
anxiety anyway so I overthink things
over think you should have overthink the
decision to [__] get this done in the
first place I just say the reply was hi
swearing varies from client to client
yes I'm gonna vary that much though have
you taken the histamines
to help bring down sohere fever me my
bucket lips about a drop off you cut one
side it is massive long one side is
massive love and if you watched me was
flawless cosmetics who are very
well-known FIDIC flawless cosmetics what
a [__] ironic name for the [__]
company yet also I wonder why she's
throwing them under the bus a little bit
here so well you would one of the risks
of it like you they might not have put
anything wrong so you might just be
allergic we had dr. Usher he's an actual
plastic surgeon you know he has all the
right training to do something if
anything he could he is capable of way
more than stuff like this so I think
he's wasted in the industry companies
are sending beauticians who do day
courses and act like they're capable of
[__] around with people's lips and
stuff like that and that's where things
like this happen and I'm glad she's put
a story out there but and sometimes the
pursuit of perfection goes wrong next on
this morning we're gonna be talking to a
guy who accidentally [__] himself Brian
I have a vlogger for you today this guy
is called bootleggers and he's been sent
to us by quite a few people they want us
to watch him he's quite the character
first thing I thought of you know return
to the Jedi at the end when they take
off the mask of Darth Vader he reminds
me of him
there's more old people just hanging out
in the corner that a 55 year old white
English man probably with two Thai women
who look like they're sort of being
bought by him what do you say he's a
council dwelling daughter that his
missus is that he's away with Catherine
Tate
such a weird little man as he just keeps
also making all the big cliched jokes so
if someone gets one beer he goes oh and
you're like I'm suffering one pair with
lunch and he's like you love to drink it
just make you realize how [__] London is
when you watch this thing if I end up
making likes of half the money off of
these cons on YouTube of me I'll appear
in the next video and he may have a
[__] beach like yep this is me yeah
so it yes and then all of a sudden it
just pans out in this three [__] tie
we've been doing the washing in the back
all right lads officially officially
they prefer me for lads man it's
ingrained in their massive [__] looking
and feeling his microphone is trained on
everything but him this man could give
you the best sound cement about him
though I'm a bit I'm not too sure about
it he's took it he's taking his wife and
he looks a bit like mr. bean he's
freaking me out
I do like him he's not as innocent as
blue I love some clever clogs forgot to
bring the Lila and the towels didn't
they Claire
he's got the luff of a serial killer
let's go yep we're gonna kill you see
it's gonna make a lovely blow first kill
this couldn't listen to this I mean that
looks beautiful
yeah I think it's got a bit because
using the [__] Star Wars music this
isn't Tatooine yeah you're the fun to
menace yeah goodbye yeah an old clip
Beach the way he talks is so weird
goodbye yeah and long family one
bohemian backpackers extravaganza
continues Wow this is a man on a holiday
the bohemian back Turkish extravaganza
continues I like that he could easily be
a murderer this guy I feel like he could
murder someone not only a fool would
walk into a hotel guys if it turns out
oh my god the [__] me to be honest the
less you say about this fool the better
I love it when people sign this weird
[__] like this thumb you know whoever
sent this tongues appreciate wider
question who went out of their way to
give this video two dislikes and are
they still alive there's one of them and
he's trucked down the other of them in
cold blood yeah probably
the alkies they were hanging out with at
lunch as his killer though me to call me
a fool less said about this fool the
better this is terrifying he just blew a
snot oh Lord or any ghost for four
matches as well you've got more to come
yeah if I thought that was say yeah so
Brian and I have come back to the page
where he came last week for Jesus's
morning routine because Jesus had a
morning routine and I'm gonna open up a
couple of the channels that are related
to her channel but Wow and we're just
gonna see what they are so this first
one is called the battle against sexual
immorality and lust and pornography
well that's very graphic literally put
in you and a whole lot of people save
God has been doing things among the you
know 18 to 30 year olds God look at his
demos and the thought I need to get by
18 to 30 crowd some of these new convert
some of these new Christians they're
there all the sudden coming into a
measure of spiritual warfare that I
think when they were first saved they
never anticipated and I've heard veteran
Christians measuring Christians veterans
this man I'm a veteran Christian I've
seen it all I served in the crib I
served in the Bible there are passions
of the flesh that wage war that means
there are there are passions that would
seek to wage war and destroy your soul
you might look at her awesome tits and
you might want to touch them but it's
saying don't do that to be fair that's a
good point Brian sometimes sex can
distract from the soul second destruct
from a lot of things yeah I often wonder
what would my life be like without it
you'd be [__] Einstein I'd have 10
million subs at least minimum that's why
daddy's at nine point seven yeah why
should you pay regard to me
a dead dog and I say the same why did
the Lord PEI regard to me a dead dog a
flea a worm talking himself down here I
feel like it's quite low self esteem for
some ways presenting YouTube he likes
being degraded that's why they can't
film him from the waist down yeah he's
got a stonking erection right now his
problem that's why I'm here to testify
today because I believe the Lord will be
glorified for me testifying to the the
great salvation that has been all of the
grace of God you need to pay the grace
of the barbershop okay good I started to
take notice of the magazines and the
checkout aisles and at 12 years old I
got heavily addicted to pornography all
right okay so he's one of those guys
that when you're 12 you're not addicted
to pornography you're just looking at
[__] things you've not seen before
but the mother walks in she sees him
once and she knows you are a Wharram a
flea you have a pornography addiction
you've got your dick in your hand all
day your little [__] wanker and your
daddy get home he gonna beat you with
his belt boy oh no I'm so sorry don't
tell daddy about my pornography
addiction mama my dick so hard I can't
stop one you little pervert keep on
touching the corner are you gonna make
yourself calm I've seen your daddy do it
you look just like him that's the same
face he get go on finish it pin it and
that's when he realized he wanted to
[__] his mother yes right or at least I
think I've channeled through the portals
Oh see No
years of my life I was a slave of it
whether it would be from internet or
magazines or wherever it would be I was
living for lost the way he's put you
know wanting to [__] women being your
drive in your life right it's done me
wonders to me what's he done I've lived
for lost yeah I've made a lot of money
I've done great things I great things
exactly I got myself off of the Council
of state and so I turn my life around
you know I mean I'm an outstanding
taxpaying citizen and I've just you've
only just come out to date I finally got
myself into paying the tax man yeah but
then I was I was taking from the estate
I was a leech I was a leech like this
guy I couldn't afford a good shirt just
like this guy yeah now because of
lausanne affording a charity situation
you don't wear that someone else for me
right so don't put it down this is real
gold sometimes lust is the way forward
sometimes this is the way forward these
rings are solid gold yeah don't knock it
yeah look like a cheap tacky look but to
Brian that is status hey guys my name is
Amy Jean and welcome back to my channel
today's video is going to cover what the
Bible says about sex hello amia I don't
feel like Amy is a woman who would like
to be objectified in that well I don't
think either I'm just she looks she or
touch she totally your type she's girl
next door no I'm not being honest I I
like to think our women but she's pretty
I'll give her that
no I think she is one sex created only
for making children sex wasn't created
at all it was developed for evolution
you dumb [__]
I've already had sex so what now
basically I [__] up what do I do
wait until marriage can be really
challenging it will require an even
deeper relationship with God and
discipline but the reward top-notch
she's talking about sex she's saying if
you wait until marriage with sex better
[__] you wouldn't know [__]
because you [__] so much in your life
you lost God sometimes you can meet
someone and think yeah you'll be good in
bed right and you are wrong some names
just doesn't work like that confidence
is a good indicator you have any time
for anyone who's low on confidence
putting the time in and being a good
tutor can be very rewarding let's talk
about masturbation Brian your big
masturbator yeah just a bee
one cup right hey girls Tiffany dawn
here and today we're gonna talk about a
really tough issue called drumroll
please
masturbation yes I just said it yeah
said it why do you think masturbation is
like such a taboo subject I think it's
more so for women isn't it for religious
women especially because losing they're
not really supposed to be sexual in
religion generally speaking were you you
can whine called a in the Bible or smile
on yes the first section of this video
is called is masturbation even wrong the
second section is the dangers of
masturbation I want to hear about the
dangers of masturbation let's get back
when I was single I had this group of
girlfriends and we would all hang out
and talk about everything and so one of
the things we talked about was
masturbation we've never talked about
wanking have we together because it's
sort of what's the word we don't talk
about we just leave it so give it again
but all of them said to me TIFF if
you've never started don't start aa
fight smoking once you have your first
puff you just can't stop can you
it's like yeah it's closer to you and
they said that part of it is because of
the danger that it can become addictive
that it's hard to stop once you start
you know what do you have a coffee in
the morning mmm it's just sort of
brightening your tail isn't it like you
need waking it up you have a coffee in
the Mon you feel pretty good I wouldn't
M addicted to coffee if I have one a day
to me addicted is a word that you should
be used when it's sort of controlling
your life and when it's becoming bad for
you to do that with with one and you've
got a sort of rub it raw at that point
in what way you can't continue I dunno
some friends you've got a little bit
feels doing it you know some friends got
like obsessed where they were like I
just want to go for a wank
you're like so I talked with one of my
friends about this and she wasn't
walking with God at this point and she
had masturbated regularly and then got
into a relationship with this guy and
they were having sex she said that it
kind of hurt their relationship because
she didn't need him to help her enjoy
the time like she's not doing sex right
if you masturbate and you then don't
feel like you need your partner
newsflash your partner's [__] in bet
it's a bit like food isn't it like a
once like a nice burger right I could
really go for a burger right now
you know a shag is supposed to be like a
full three-course meal where you feel
like oh yeah
yeah yeah no no I'm really full for play
cause hopefully she feels that way right
she's just going I said we just nipped
out from McDonald's that was a good
women out there don't be afraid to tell
the guy what you want and men we kind of
like being bossed around a bit I I do
anything not too much not to the extent
where it's like pick that up do this do
that in bedroom specifically men will be
quite obedient in that they not the main
aren't setting out and going I don't
wanna please that her I think some men
are [__] selfish yeah but if you got
a good part no but yeah just to help mo
just tell them what you want yeah
there's not not a problem
good communication during sex we'll give
you vice versa yeah yeah you know hey
Dad for women I'm just gonna watch
videos and I just pissed myself someone
next to me go explain a few things about
your little business he's trying to help
other wasn't like and bless her she's
like a little entrepreneur as well so
quite sweet aren't they and I bet a
couple of people from the middle and
seeing go the wife's come along just to
make sure there's no funny business
yeah he's hanging when he at the end he
goes don't do the thing you normally do
just threw them at you it's like
porridge with Lynn Lynn she's sitting
there looking at night I do I don't in
all this this is just useless info she's
a good-looking girl she probably got her
own life and life going on meet up with
the girls after work or whatever what
was your idea like the other girl makes
me put in a cafe I had this guy he
wouldn't sure about his [__] shoes
and he got somewhere you know 20 quid
work boots he said I just thought I just
got a ruby a [__] fit damn it yeah
it's pretty [__] disgusting to do you
have to be a certain kind of person you
just to be like one of the few legit
doesn't mind to her this is like you
switching on a camera look at her she's
like really inspecting yeah this is her
business so she's gonna I'm just saying
I couldn't do obviously when I was a
young and I worked in a butcher shop for
a while and I seen things where I'm like
yeah this is not everyone can do this
yeah when we first see in the blue Varma
and that you're just sitting at a table
we're big on leveling up you know
there's some youtubers you've seen a
video from two years ago you seen a
video essay it's the same [__] thing
this guy's levelling up massive we're
seeing an artist
role he's changed the palette he's
changed the painkillers
the brush has changed the canvas has
definitely changed do you know what this
his wife must think is you know some
women when their husband go out they
think our [__] getting up to phase
out their life loom with all these women
when his wife comes out she goes
everything is absolutely fine
he's literally sat in front of a woman
his feet are in the air and he's talking
about stubbing his toe after having a
pee in the middle of the day he's
everything that those Christian people
on a daily basis are trying he's
think about masturbating is not this
stuff he's just doing yeah he's living a
good life he's divine yeah he isn't
naturally divinely Batman he's a God
among us yeah move a man is Zelda oh
she's she's getting the skin off his
feet this is a working man Jeremy
working us rig a boots all day so his
skin will have hardened up considerably
for the visually impaired we're looking
a middle-aged man's all crusty feet
getting grinded yeah I could imagine
that imagine you came here for Jay Paul
I love that we suck people in for Jake
Paul am I the end you're looking at this
old English white dude get his feet
grinded this is what we do we sucker you
in and then we give you the good contest
somehow it's more compelling no a
funnier thing this old crusty foot is
more compelling than Jay Paul and Tyler
mojo who would have thunk it we get a
replay of lips moving - took my big
flapping gums into the New York stack
what a good once again it was four pound
29 I bought it from the McDonald's at
shell Thorpe in love bruh and I will
mention again the lag there said I do
look forward to your review he is famous
within the local area I love it 23,000
views I'm not surprised we're going to
get the scope 100,000 subs I love it
this is great yeah it's a good point
don't subscribe to me there we have it
it's on a ring don't think it's a bagel
doughnut sauce sweet he's got a point
they both got holes in them but it's
like comparing an ear to an ass yeah it
does actually look good I'm genuinely
like really interested to see what he
says about this because if he likes it I
will have one thing he's trying to make
that a thing
yeah oh that's gonna [__] t-shirts
that's talking yeah what's it like beef
I bet it's told me he doesn't like you
told me to told me dude please don't let
that hang there for the rest of the meal
he's got to lick that off surely he's
got pontiff we need you their regards
son Fox on my guy once again folks I'm
just
so disappointed in these beef burgers
I'll keep reviewing them and saying what
I think about them until the improve my
keys yeah sort your [__] out he will
keep on slaving you right folks just
gonna do a bit of a shout out I am
wanting the shout out sort but sometimes
they catch mine I do want to do one jeff
has stayed them is in hospital he's got
a get well soon from Dylan Butterworth
so Jeff had a bit of an accident or this
is like a local radio stations quiz I
love him
my mate from real ale craft beer they
could have changed that race what I
think is now that people have started a
really value his opinion and he's being
rated as a reviewer he's giving his
opinion on everything because obviously
in the past he'd probably say the odd
comment about what he thinks the world
should be like but now that people are
putting weight behind his opinions and I
bet he'd ever stops now
so I imagine his wife's life has changed
dramatically so he's gone from passing
the odd comment to being like well you
know any kids of those pillows never see
to the cat yeah and and now is she's
like you don't know what you're talking
about he's gonna go you soon the point
of the subscriber name ago sorry what
sorry love is that you you've got your
one opinion you one person me 42000
behind mine so who is right to fair that
is also the point where gene goes take
him back tidy mouse alright you say you
stick with you Lucas it next week yeah
three minutes in yeah not a sip of the
pudding ill see I love toffee can I get
I love toffee so if this is good I'm
gonna try - yeah exactly give it a sip
son go on get it down yet absolutely
amazing that is stunning stunning
stunning stunning
thank you very much you were stunning
leave a man on true news blue Batman on
the kick off through that man or
whatever I kind of wonder the whole pod
I just want to know what he's like in
general hopefully you have enjoyed the
show if we do have blue VAR man it's
more than likely of it on the kickoff
we've got a channel for the football
called the kickoff subscribe the link
for that is in the description below
we're trying to get 100,000 subscribers
if you want to know what we think about
football we do talk a lot of shite
apparently on that but you might like it
one of us does and yeah just like and
subscribe thanks for watching everyone
see you later hey Brian you might think
that it's like cybercrime some happens
to other people
right basically you know you we're going
to Starbucks be going towards in places
there's lots of open public Wi-Fi they
go on well there may be people on that
Wi-Fi and in the public area who look
and steal your details do you want them
have your details Brian is that
something you want know exactly Brian
that's why expressvpn are here to help
don't you yeah Thank You expressvpn for
sponsoring this week's true new social
it secures in anonymizes your internet
browsing because i write in nobody knows
it basically encrypts the data you know
the wording grow buddy knows it but
you've got a secret browser and use it
oh and live for me is that right that's
good it's not really a browser but you
feel a very good hub that jingle a fool
turning on expressvpn basically gives
you protection in one click bang on
you're protected I like real protected
for less than seven dollars a month you
can also get the same protection that
we've got from Express VPS absolutely
Brian just go to expressvpn comm forward
slash George Jordy you got it enough to
shout it I want to protect my ears to
expressvpn do anything for that flush
Georgie it's nationally important
there's always reason couple of
particular Express VB little just
crushing on life expressvpn you know
support us just do it get three free
months within a one-year package really
it's well worth I've use VPNs online and
expressvpn are about to change my life
Alex and Jack had a bit of a fallout